I get rid of those little boxes just to make our whole graph area look a little
bit cleaner. Since our x values need to range from negative five to five on this
portion of the axis that we've drawn, each of these grid lengths needs to count
for one. So, when we step from zero, one step over, we need to label that one,
two, three, and so on. And you see we get to five on the positive edge of the
axis. Counting in the negative direction, we had the same scale. So, we have
negative 1, negative 2. And you can see, I even made a mistake when I was
drawing these axes. I made our x-axis one longer than it needed to be, which
doesn't really hurt us, so I'm going to leave it as is. I apologize for my lack
of perfection here. Now, in the y-direction, we need to be able to go from
positive 10 all the way down to negative 20. We have 5 boxes up here and 10
boxes down here. So, that means we need to count by 2s with each step of teh
graph. So, moving from 0 up one box, is going to actually be stepping 2 in the
y-direction and then down into the same scale again. Now, again, the point of
creating these scales and these limited links for either access is really just
to make our lives easier a little bit when we're graphing. The x and y values
for this graph do extend, actually, all the way from negative infinity to
positive infinity. We're only going to graph part of that infinitely long line,
in particular, the part that shows these values on this graph.